hi everybody
can you hear me
yes good
um
welcome back uh
to um
to the course and um
so we are now at lecture 10 and um uh
i
let's see what have we been doing we've
been talking about um
undecidability
um so we
introduced last time
uh reducibilities and mapping
reducibilities for proving
various problems are undecidable
and
this time we're going to and today we're
going to introduce a a
more sophisticated method for proving
undecidability uh using reduceabilities
and that's called the computation
history method and and that's pretty
much
what's
used in all of the
you know more
serious cases where people have proved
problems undecidable it's it's pretty
much a widespread uh
uh method for uh especially you know
it's not an active area of research
these days but at times when people were
proving problems undecidable
this was frequently a method that was
used
um so we'll go over that today and we'll
prove um
a few examples of problems undecidable
using that method
all right so why don't we get started um
uh so first of all
most importantly
you should remember how we you how we
prove um problems are undecidable in the
first place
and that is by showing
um some other undecidable problem that
we already know is undecidable is
reducible to the problem of interest
so typically you might be reducing atm
um which is a problem that we started
with and showed to be undecidable by the
diagonalization method
um or might be some other problem that
we've subsequently shown to be
undecidable and you take that problem
and you reduce it to
the problem you're trying to show
undecidable
okay oops
let me fix that
sorry
um
so um
so this is the thing to keep in mind to
prove a language is undecidable show
that atm or some other known undecidable
language is reducible to the problem b
that you have at hand that you're trying
to show undecidable
all right so we are now going to
um
um
[Music]
first i'm going to start off by
remembering um hilbert's 10th problem
which we discussed briefly a few
lectures back um
and as you may remember
so that's a problem where uh you're
given
say some polynomial
you know over several variables
you know like three x squared y minus
15z
plus
2xz
equals 5.
and you want to solve that problem
you want to find a solution
that solves that equation
but you require that the solution
involves only integers
so those are so called diaphantine
problems because the requirement is that
the solution being integers
and
hilbert's problem was to
ask for a
an algorithm
not the language that he used but
doesn't matter he essentially he asked
for an algorithm to test whether a
polynomial has a solution in integers or
the polynomial equation has a solution
in integers
and um
as
uh
um
uh
um as we now know that problem was posed
back in 1900
it took 71 years to find the solution
but the answer is no
there is no there is no such algorithm
we talked about this when we were
discussing the church turing thesis
um
and um
the method
showing
that there is no algorithm is by a
reduction from atm to that problem
so one can use exactly the method that
we're using today to prove that problem
is undecidable
about polynomials the only thing is is
that the reduction that single reduction
would take the entire semester
um
and i know that's
in fact correct because when i was a
graduate student um there was a woman in
the math department at berkeley where i
where i studied and she uh the whole the
whole course
was to go through the proof of hilbert's
tenth problem
um of the solution to hillary problem
the the proof of the undecidability of
the uh of the solution
uh of the undecidability of testing
whether a polynomial has an integral
solution um
so
um
the thing is that involves some
fairly hairy number theory in order to
um
to come up with the right polynomials to
basically simulate the turing machine
which so that's kind of getting ahead of
ourselves that's what we're going to be
doing today um but we're going to
instead of looking at that problem
because we don't have a whole semester
to spend on it um we're going to look at
a toy problem instead
where there's no number theory but it
still has the same basic underlying idea
um to that that was employed in um the
solution to hilbert's tenth problem
um so that toy problem is called the
post correspondence problem
and it's going to have some other
utility for us
well
the main reason we're studying it is
just to illustrate the method um
uh
so
and the method is going to be as i've
been saying is this computation history
method
okay so one we will first talk about uh
this post-correspondence problem because
that's very easy to understand
and then we'll spend a little time
introducing that method
um
all right
so um
the
uh the post the post correspondence
problem is
as follows you're given
uh
a bunch of pairs of strings
um so here is
one pair t1 and b1
and i'm writing them as
dominoes i'm calling them dominoes
because i'm writing one pair one one of
the strings on top of the other string
in fact i'm
using t and b for top and bottom here so
this is t1 is the top string b1 is the
bottom string in the first domino
and then in the second domino we have
two other strings to a top and a bottom
and so on
um
so we have these here
uh this collection of dominoes
um
as
sort of the legal dominoes um and what
the goal is to find a sequence of those
dominoes um
uh
so you want to pick from these dominoes
here you're allowed to repeat dominoes
so you want to pick a sequence of those
dominoes
line them up next to each other
and so that the string that you get by
reading along the top all of the t's
together
is going to be exactly the same as the
string you get by reading along all the
bottoms
i'll give you an example
um so here to write it down a little bit
more formally
so uh what i'm calling a match
is a sequence of these dominoes so it's
t i1 ti2
as well it's it's i1 is the first domino
i2 is the second domino and so on
and then you what you're going to have
is
all the top strings concatenated
concatenated together is exactly the
same as what you get by concatenating
together all the bottom strings
um so here's an example and i think
it'll become clear if you didn't
understand it so far but it'll be
completely clear from the example i hope
so here is a bunch of dominoes
um four
um
and um
what i wanna know is is there some
selection of these dominoes again you
can repeat dominoes otherwise it would
be not an interesting problem so you can
repeat these as many times as you like
and i want to pick up pick these
dominoes and line them up so that what
you get by reading along the top is the
same as what you get by reading along
the bottom
so first of all if you just stare at
this
and you're trying to make a match
you'll see that there's only one
possibility possible way to start this
um you know
for example if you started with the
third domino here b a over a a
it would fail immediately because
um you know the b and the a are
different
um and and if you you use the second
domino as your starting point that would
fail the match as well
because a a has to would have to e um be
the the the top string would start with
a a the bottom string would start with a
b and they could never be equal
um so by looking at this you can see
that the only possible choice that you
have is to start with the first domino
okay so i'm going to start to build the
domino for you just so you can see it so
here's the very the the match as um so
you can see um the process so the match
starts with the very first domino and
the way i'm going to write it is i'm
going to take the dominoes and kind of
skew them
so that you can see how the top and
bottom strings are lining up
um
but they're just mouth the same dominoes
they've just been
i changed the shape
so this is the first domino a b over aba
now uh the second domino in my and my
match it's gotta start with an a
as the leftmost symbol on the top string
so that would rule out this one for
example um but there might be several
choices and so it's not exactly obvious
which one you should take
what i'm going to suggest is we take
this one here
so we take a a over a b a you see it a a
over a b a it's just
you know written i'm just skewing uh
skewing it so that um i can line up the
a over a the b over b the a over a and
so on so i'm starting to build
this concatenation of the top being
equal to the concatenation of the bottom
following me so far i hope
so now um what's what's next so i need
to have something where
the top string is going to start with a
ba
in fact there's only one choice for that
so it's clearly going to have to be this
domino is going to be next so it's going
to put a ba up here but then it's going
to a force an a a down below because
that's what this domino does um
so this ba matches with that now we have
the aaa
to deal with um
so
we're going to reuse this domino because
that's the only one that starts with an
aa so we're going to reuse that one
now we have a a and aba now we need
something that starts with aba
i see two choices
it could be this one because this is
consistent with a it's at least it
captures the a b we could we could try
putting this one over here but a better
choice would it be would be to use this
one because if we use this one we finish
the match
and therefore we have found what we're
looking for
um and this
this
this collection of
dominoes here has a mat has a match
now it's not always obvious
some some collections of dominoes may
not have a match
and so the computational problem is
is there a match
um
and
the theorem that we're going to prove
today is that this problem is
undecidable
simple as it is simple little
combinatorial problem of you know uh
trying to put together different um
uh different tiles like that to form
form a match
uh there was no algorithm for solving
that problem
um and and i think this is kind of
interesting because it's the first
example of a problem that we have where
the underlying
question
does not really seem to have anything to
do with computation
you know you might argue that atm being
undecidable
is perhaps
a little unsurprising after the fact
because you know it's a problem about
touring machines so you can imagine
turing machines are going to have a
tough time answering it um but here's a
problem just about strings
um and we're going to show it's
undecidable
so
just to formulate this as a language i'm
going to call the pcp language
is the collection of these um
uh
pcp
uh problems pcp instances which are just
collect themselves each one is a
collection of dominoes so it's the
language of all
uh collections of these dominoes where
there is a match
so it's all of the pcp problems where
you can solve them with a match
and
uh we're going to prove that it's
undecidable by showing that atm is
reducible to that pcp language
um now uh before we do that i'm going to
have to i'm going to explain to you what
the computation history method is in the
first place that we're going to be using
uh so before we do that here's our first
check-in for the day
just to make sure you're following me
about
uh what the um
what this pcp problem is
i am
going to give you
a question to
uh
test
is there a match
with these three dominoes
so what you think about that
i mean the main thing i'm i want to make
sure you understand is what a match is
in the first place this is not a super
hard problem
uh to tell whether or not there's a
match
okay
um
five seconds
already
okay
closing it out um
okay um
so
uh
for those of you who said there is a
match
i want you to
exhibit exhibit the match because in
fact there is no such map there is no
match
um
and uh i mean you could get by fiddling
around with it i think if you try to
find a match you'll pretty quickly uh
see that it's you're gonna get um i
think what happens is you kind of get
into if you try to build build a match
with this particular setup
you're just going to get stuck
sort of repeating yourself and
um
one point here that you may have missed
is that a match has to be a finite
sequence
so if you were thinking about there
there is there is a kind of an infinite
match uh that you can build with this uh
this this set of dominoes but that's not
allowed we're only allowing finite
matches
and so that may they might change your
answer as a result but too late um
so
um
and one way to see that you can't have a
uh a match in this problem is that you
know you're going to have to start
you you
you know neither of these two are
possible starting points so this one is
going to be clearly the only chance that
you're going to have as a match uh the
first domino here but then once you put
this one down
um the bottom one the bottom string the
the bottom b's that you're going to get
the bottom string is going to be longer
than the top string
and then the other two are going to be
have the same length um so you're never
going to have the bottom uh the top be
the same length as the bottom the bottom
is always going to be longer no matter
how many uh
more dominoes you lay out so this
there's no chance of there being a match
here um
okay
so now we're gonna
um
uh
work our way up to introducing this
computation history method
[Music]
um um
first
let me
define something for a turing machine
that i'm going to call a configuration
um
configuration is just a snapshot of the
turing machine in the middle of its
computation
so
if you're running the turing machine and
you just
stop it at some moment
it's going to be in a certain state
the head is going to be on a certain
position
and the tape is going to have a certain
contents
and with that information
you can then um continue the copy the
computation of the turing machine that's
a full set of the information that you
need about the turing machine that tells
you everything about its cut its
computation at that moment in time
the state head position and tape
contents and so that we're calling that
that information together
uh state head position tape contents
we're calling that a configuration it's
a
fairly
um
basic notion i mean if you if you
program if you have something if you
have like the states of all the
variables and where the current
execution of the program is at
a moment in time same idea
um
okay so in terms of a picture here here
is the turing machine
imagine it's in state q3
um the head position is in the sixth
position on the tape so
p would be six
um because it's in the sixth position
and the tape contents is going to be
this bunch of a's followed by this bunch
of b's so i would write it down like
this
states in q3
head position number six
this is the contents of the tape
um now what we're going to often do
for convenience in using this notion in
proofs
is that we're going to want to represent
a con
a configuration as a string
um
in a particular way that's going to be
that's going to
this is this concept is going to come up
kind of
again and again during the during during
uh the course and so it's going to be
handy to have a particular way of
writing down configurations
um
you know for doing um
proofs about them and so the way we're
going to write them down is
i think it's just maybe i can just put
it right up here like this
um
we're going to write down
the
the symbols of the tape
but what we're going to do is stick in
the middle of those symbols the the
state
of the machine
immediately to the left
of the
position that the machine is currently
reading
so you can imagine
you know the the head here which is
coming you know imagine the state is
kind of where the head is it's pointing
at the symbol immediately to its right
so this is just another way of writing
down a configuration here's the tape
contents which i'm i'm sort of writing
formally here i'm breaking the the the
the tape contents into two parts which
i'm calling t1 and t2
um this is the t1 part the t2 part
and i'm
putting the uh
the
the state
in between t1 and t2
where i have in mind that the machine's
head position is right at the beginning
of t2
but maybe this picture just says it all
and it's clear enough
um
so just keep in mind that when when
we're going to be writing down
configurations of machines we're
typically going to write it down this
way
um
okay so i think this is a good moment to
take uh to take a moment uh for
questions
oh i see there's a lot of questions
already um
um so one's question is how does the
encoding differentiate between the
string and the state
um
i if i'm understanding you correctly i'm
going to be assuming
that um
the state the symbols that represent
states and the symbols that appear on
the tape
are distinct from one another so you can
always tell just like usually the way we
write things down when you have a state
symbol or whether you have a tape symbol
and so in a configuration you're going
to have a bunch
of uh tape symbols and a single state
symbol represent you know in the
position where the head is
um
somebody says
6 here is just you know this is one two
three four five six we're in head the
head is in position six that's all i had
in mind for six and that's why that six
is appearing over there because that's
the position of the head
um
good
all right
so why don't we continue um
now we're all ready to start defining
computation histories
um which themselves is not very
difficult concept
computation history for a turing machine
m on an input w
is just the sequence of configurations
you go through
when you start the machine
at the beginning
um with uh m on the um
on the tape
with w on the tape i'm sorry um and then
and the
the st the head at the beginning is in
position one
and the uh state in q zero or whatever
the start state is of the machine
so
that's going to be the very the starting
configuration here and these are the
sequence of configuration that mean
machines go through that the machine
goes through step by step
every step of the machine is getting
represented here until it ends up at an
accept
that's what we mean by a computation
history or sometimes we're going to
emphasize that by calling and accepting
computation history
represent meaning that the machine has
accepted its input and these are the
sequence of configurations that the
machine goes through
that's what i mean by a computation
history you know i'm sure in i mean i
think the terminology changes over the
years but the there's a notion similar
to that
for any kind of um you know if you're
you know running a program
and you just want to keep track of how
the variables are changing um as you're
you know in this particular run of the
machine and you're writing them all down
um it's like a log of the uh
history of the settings of the internal
states of the machine and variables and
so on
um
so this is just all of the
configurations the machine goes through
are on the way to accepting its input
if the machine does not accept its input
there is no computation history
okay so there is no accepting
computation history at least to
emphasize that point um
because that can only occur obviously if
the machine has accepted its input
okay so just as we had with
configurations
we're going to might want to be able to
write down computation histories as
strings
and it'll be convenient to have a
particular format for doing that as well
and it's kind of the obvious thing
we're just going to take
[Music]
the sequence of configurations in the
computation history and write them down
as a string where each
configuration is going to be the string
for that configuration
i'll show you kind of a little example
in a second but just to
you know focus on the concept here we're
just going to write down the string for
this configuration the starting
configuration and then the next
configuration and so on until you get to
the accepting configuration and separate
each of those strings by some pound sign
okay so here is a computation history
for m on w um
[Music]
uh
where w is the string w on w2 dot wn
so here is the uh
here is the first
uh configuration
so that this part here is that is the
computation history encoded as a string
i'm just i'm giving you this extra
um
side information just to make it clearer
what's what's going on there so this is
the first configuration this is the
second configuration and so on and i'm
i'm trying to even give you a little bit
more you know um detail of how it might
look uh by kind of
you know making the example a little bit
more concrete so let's say that the
turing machine
when it's in the starting state q0
looking at the very first symbol of of
the end of the the input tape in this
particular input say w1
um it goes from q0 to q7 and writes an a
on the tape and moves its head to the
right
so that's why the second configuration
reflects that
see here it went from q0 to q7
now the head is in the second position
so that's why that state symbol has
moved over one
and
um
the very first position now has become
an a
because the machine has changed whatever
was on that
input tape there on the first position
to an a
and then the next step it goes from q7
reading w2 which is where the head is uh
now it's looking at the w2
and goes to q8 writing a c and again
moves right
okay so that's why i drew these in the
way i did and so you go through a
sequence of those you get to cue accept
and that's
the encoded form of the computation
history
all right
um
i think that's is that all i wanted to
say yeah um
so you can uh feel free
to ask another question if you want um
i'm just gonna relaunch this
yeah good
so if you for all to for all together on
configurations
computation histories
and how we're going to be writing them
down as strings
that's what we've done so far
no questions so i'm going to move on
all right
so let me define a new
um automaton
that we're going to
mainly use
as uh just
to
provide an example
for us
today
i'm going to call this a linearly
bounded automaton
and all it is is a turing machine
[Music]
where the turing machine is going to be
restricted
in where it can uh
the tape is not going to be infinite
anymore the tape is just going to be big
enough to hold the input
so the machine no longer has the ability
to move into the portion of the tape to
the right of the input because there is
no tape out there it just has the tape
sitting here um that contains the input
which can the tape itself can vary in
size however big the input is that's how
big the tape is
so the tape adjusts to the length of the
input
but once you've started the machine with
some particular input that's as big as
the tape is there's no more
um the reason why it's called linearly
bounded is because the amount of memory
is a linear function of the of the size
of the input because you can effectively
get
somewhat more memory by enlarging the
tape alphabet
but that's going to be fixed for any
given machine so that's
where the linear comes from if that's
helpful but if you don't get that
that's
sort of a side remark
uh
but um
what's important to me is that your
understand what i mean by an uh a
linearly bounded automaton or an lba
it's just like a turing machine but this
that portion of the tape that originally
had blanks is just not there
the machine tries to move its head off
the off the right end of the input it
just sticks there just as if it tried to
move its head off the left end of the
input
doesn't go anywhere
okay so now i'm gonna we're gonna ask
the same kinds of questions about lbas
that we asked for other automata
so the acceptance problem
if i give you a
an input
and some particular
lba
and i want to know
does the lba accept that input
well you know and now the question is is
that decidable um or not
uh so
it's
um at first glance you might think well
um an lba is like a turing machine
and the atm problem is undecidable
so uh
you know that that might be a good first
guess
um
[Music]
and also if you try to uh
to simulate them if you try to figure
out how you would go about simulating
the machine um
you know if you if a given b and w if
you actually try to simulate the machine
to get the answer so you run b on w well
of course if you run it for a while and
it eventually halts either accepting or
rejecting then you know the answer and
you're finished but you know this
machine might get into a loop
um
you know nothing to prevent the machine
from looping on that finite amount of on
that limited amount of tape that it has
um and then
you know
you might be in trouble
but in fact that's not the case
because
when you start out with a limited amount
of tape
if you run the machine for a long time
and it's not holding it's going and
going and going
inevitably it's going to have to repeat
um
get into exactly the same configuration
that it did before because there's only
a limited number of configurations that
the machine has
and once it repeats a configuration it's
going to be repeating that configuration
forever and it's going to be in a loop
so
this problem in fact is decidable um
because the idea is if bmw runs for for
a very long time and
an amount that you can calculate then
you know it's got to be you know cycling
you know more than just looping it's got
to be repeating itself
um
and so therefore once it starts
repeating itself it's going to be going
forever
so um and here's the actual calculation
which is something i'm sure you could do
on your own but just to spell it out
so if you have an input of length n
um that you're providing to uh b so if w
is of length n
um the the lba can only go
uh for
uh this number of different it can only
have this number of different
configurations the number of states
times the number of head positions which
is n the number of head positions on the
tape
times the number of different tape
contents
you know if if the tape was only one
long you know this is the this is the
size of the tape alphabet so if the tape
were too long it would you know
had the tape had two
uh
two cells on it the number of possible
tape contents is would be um the square
of the of the alphabet and then and if
if the tape is going to be n
uh symbols long it's going to be
the tape alphabet size to the nth power
uh so therefore if a turning machine
runs for longer it's got to repeat
some configuration and it'll never hold
so the decider is going to be
hopefully uh clear at this point
you're given b and w
says that this is the decider for alba
it's going to run bmw for this number of
steps
if it's accepted by then then you accept
and if it hasn't if it's rejected or
it's still running
then you can reject and you know if it's
still running at this point it's never
going to accept
all right
any questions on this
okay let's move on
um
all right so now um
but what's different now or what's it
perhaps interesting now is that even
though the
acceptance problem for lbas is the is is
decidable
the emptiness problem is undecidable
and that's where the computation history
method is going to come in so this is
where we're going to be starting to do
something new in terms of a proof
technique
um because
so we're going to reduce atm to elba the
emptiness problem for lbas
um
so given an lba does it accept anything
or not
and this is going to use the computation
history method so
this will be a chance to illustrate that
method for the first time
so this the setup initially is just like
before we're going to assume we have a
turing machine that decides the cb elba
problem that of interest
and we're going to use that to construct
turing machine deciding atm for our
contradiction
okay so here's s
supposedly deciding atm
what it's going to do and this is going
to be the tricky part
s
is going to use m and w to design an
llba
that lba
is going to be built
with the knowledge of m w in fact it's
going to have m and w built into it
so
that's why i'm calling that lba
b sub mw
because it depends on mw
um
as i'll describe and what that lba does
it takes its input
let's call it the x the input to the the
lba
and
examines that input to see
if that input is an accepting
computation history for m on w
then that lba is just looking for
computation histories for mw
and that's the only thing it's going to
ever accept
if you feed it something which is not
a computation history you know that
sequence of configurations
uh for mmw leading to an accept if you
feed it something else
the lba is just going to reject it
it only accepts
the accepting computation history for m
w
and now
if you can build such a thing
then
you can
use that machine
in your emptiness tester to see if it
accepts any strings at all
because the only thing that could
possibly be accepting is an accepting
computation history you don't even know
if there exists one because you don't
know if m accepts w
so you're going to build this lba
um
and uh
which is looking for accepting
computation histories
and then see if its language is empty or
not
if its language is not empty
the only thing it could be accepting is
this computation history so you know m
except w
whereas if the language is empty you
know that there is no computation
history for m w and so m does not accept
the leaf
so that's the whole idea the trick is
how do you build
this uh this lba um
so first you're going to make this lba
which tests its input to see if it's an
accepting computation history for m on w
and you have to build this
um
uh lba without even knowing whether
there is a computation history
um it's not like you can take that
string and just build the string into
the lba because they don't even know if
that string exists
but what you can do
is you can make the lba
um
follow the rules of m it knows w
and knows m so it can test take the its
input and using w and the rules of m see
if that input is a computation history
for m and w
um and that's what it's going to do
so here is
um
this machine i'm going to construct i'll
i'll give it to you written down and
with a little bit more um details of its
procedure but just to kind of illustrate
it so here is a proposed input to b sub
mw this would be the x here this would
be an x that would be accepted
but anything else that would be provided
would not be accepted
so this is the sequence of
configurations written down as a string
that would be the x that i'm providing
to the b c b b sub mw and it's supposed
to be checking this to make sure it's
legit
um so
so on on input x the way it's gonna the
way it's going to proceed
it's going to first check to see whether
x begins in the right way
because you know
this lba it knows m and it knows w
so the very first thing is it takes a
look at the first part of the string up
to the pound sign you know there's no
pound sign if you're going to just feed
junk in it's going to be easily
identifiable as junk
um
so uh
you know if you're going to feed
something so it's going to the lba is
going to take everything up to the first
pound sign and just confirm that that
thing is
the first configuration the starting
configuration of um
of m on w which means it has to start
with the start state and here is w
so just going to check that
um
then it's going to check that each
each one of these guys follows legally
from the previous one according to the
rules of f it's going to first checks
that this one is correct and then this
one leads to that one
according to the rules of m then this
one leads to that one according to the
rules of m
all of that you know the knowledge of m
and w is built in so it can do that
um
and then it just
follows along checking this computation
you know it's easy to check that a
computation is correct that's all that's
really going on here
um
it's going to check that the computation
is correct until it gets to the end and
then make sure that the last uh
configuration that it's been given as
input is an accepting configuration
that there's an accept state in it
um and if everything that passes it it
accepts otherwise it uh rejects
okay
um
and the point is that this is an lba you
don't oh i just kind of jumped ahead of
myself you don't need any additional
information so how does it actually do
this
so you know how do you actually do this
on the tape so i claim that the lba
doesn't need any extra space to do this
um to do this check you know it's just
going to be zigzagging back and forth
here on the on on the
on the input
you know checking that the corresponding
symbols match up except around the the
head position where it gets updated or
correctly
and it seems it may need to mark it will
need to mark on the tape it's allowed to
write on the tape just to make sure it
keeps track of where it is
but this is a very simple
i mean i'm not trying to uh if you're
not following i'm not trying to uh alarm
you but i'm just trying to help you
understand that
this is not a complicated procedure here
to do this check that the that the
actual computation of the that's written
down of the turing machine is valid
um but you know we can deal with a
question here
uh
oh good
now we got some questions
oops
you can be thinking about while i'm
thinking about this you can think about
that uh check-in over there
so here's a good question
going from each configuration to the
next configuration is it a unique
uh next
step
um well i'm assuming that the turing
machine we're starting with is
deterministic so this should be only one
way to go so the answer to that
question is yes
this is going to be a unique
um string here there's really going to
be only one
um
computation history not that it really
matters in a sense um the answer to that
question um
as long as that accepting computation
history corresponds to the machine
actually accepting
uh oh boy we're all
all over the place here uh okay
are you ready to end this um
in this um
in this bowl
uh
all right
well this is where we are
uh
everybody who said they'd rather be in
six or four fig six or four six i know
who you are
you're all
going to be expelled
no i'm joking uh
i don't know who you are so um
uh
yeah good
so um
uh
wha what so we are here at the at the
break
um i and i made this poll on purpose uh
at this moment so we can spend a little
time let me just start our clock going
and i can try to help you those of you
who are who answered see that you're
baffled um
i'll i can try to uh help you understand
what's going on
all right so this is a this is a good
question here um
uh
okay well okay there's several good
questions here so um
somebody asks why don't we just test all
possible strings uh for b remember if
we're trying to test emptiness
for b's language
um
that's the e-lba problem
nor do we just try all possible strings
um
and uh
that would work if we had enough time
but there's infinitely many strings and
so that's not going to be good if we're
trying to be a decider
so
so that is
that's why we don't just try all strings
so but here's this other question here
this is a
okay
so
um
the question is how do we find the input
x
so this is an important question um
because
uh
we don't find the input x
there's no
you know we
the input x um at least the accepted
input x would be the accepting
computation history
um
for m on w
we're never going to find it
you know we're never going to find an x
we're not we're building this um this
lba
not we're never going to run that lba
we're designing that lba not for the
purposes of running it
we're building that lba only for the
purpose
of
uh using the lba language emptiness
tester we're going to build that end lba
and feed it into the machine turing
machine r
which is going to tell us whether that
lba's language is empty we ourselves is
not never going to run that machine
we're never going to come up with an x
we're just having we're we're we are
designing a computation
checker
and then
um
the emptiness tester for that
that we assumed to exist for for
elba is going to say yes there is some
computation
which this machine accepts or no there
is no computation which this machine
accepts and that's going to be a
computation for m on w
and so that's going to tell us whether
or not m accepts w
so we're never going to actually be
finding an x we're never going to be
running that lba
we're just feeding using that lba
as
as an input
to r
um
does the computation history method
always use lbas no
as you'll see uh right after the break
because that's the lbas is just
kind of an easy place to get started but
we're going to use the computation
history method and computation histories
next on the on the post correspondence
problem
yes the the computation histories and
the input x are always going to be
finite
so that that was an answer to a question
about whether these histories or the
inputs are going to be finite or not so
the the they're all those strings are
always going to be finite and the
computation history is going to be
finite
um
so we are at the end of our five minutes
um let me just see if there was another
question i wanted to answer
um
let me let's move on
okay now
getting coming back to the
undecidability of this
post-correspondence problem so remember
the post course upon you know this this
problem you're given those dominoes you
want to know if there's a match here is
a little mini version of the the diagram
if that helps you remember it um
and we're going to prove
that this language is undecidable and so
it's undecidable to test whether
you have
a match given a set of dominoes
whether a match is possible
and we're going to use we're going to
reduce atm to to this language using the
computation history method so how in the
world are we going to do that
um
first of all there's a little detail
here i want to mention
uh just
uh um
don't focus on this but
i'm going to assume the matches always
start
with the very first domino on the list
um the very first domino in the
collection
so this is going to be like a starting
domino this is going to make my proof a
little simpler to do it that way and
then you can fix that assumption uh
later and if we have time at the end
i'll do that or maybe after the lecture
is over if there are questions i can
show you how to fix that assumption but
for now
um to simplify the proof we're going to
assume that there is a starting
domino that the matches always have to
start with that particular domino
um
if you didn't follow that point don't
worry you can just ignore it you'll see
where it comes up later
so um now we're going to reduce atm to
the pcp
so assuming we have a machine that
decides the pcp we're going to use that
to make a machine that decides the atm
as before so here's the turing machine s
which is going to decide atm
um
and the way we're going to do it is like
this
we're given m and w we want to know
as always
does m accept w
what we're going to do is we're going to
build an instance
of the pcp problem so we're going to
build a bun a collection of dominoes
[Music]
uh which are going to dip
and that collection is going to be built
knowing m w so that's going to affect
the dominoes we're going to create so
this collection of dominoes is going to
be called p sub mw
depends on an m w
and
finding a match for this set of w
is is going to force you to simulate
m on w because the match is going to
correspond to a computation history for
m on w
so uh we're going to use
once we do that
um once we build
uh the set of dominoes who's where a
match corresponds to a computation
history
we're going to use r to determine
whether or not there is a match
or in other words whether or not there
is a computation history which is
whether or not m accepts w
um so if there is a match we're going to
accept because we know m accepts w
and if and if there is no uh match we're
going to reject
because we know m does not accept w
okay um
this is the plan i haven't told you how
to do this yet
i mean i'm worried about the
significant number of you who are
feeling um
confused by the method i mean you should
you guys should be uh texting me in the
tas
um to try to at least get a sense of how
this is working i mean that we're going
to be going
we're going to be doing the method again
um it's just going to be a little more
complicated because we have to also deal
with these dominoes and all this all
that stuff and that's why i presented it
to the fir to you the first time
in the setting of the lbas which where
in a sense the method comes out
perhaps more simply
so a match is going to correspond to an
accepting computation history
um sometimes i
if i don't use the word accepting
um
you know i'm just
being a little sloppy
computation history and accepting
computation history for us right now
they're the same
i mean later on we may actually talk
about rejecting computation histories
but
let's not
get ourselves confused
all the except computation histories
always have to end with the machine
accepting
okay uh somebody's asking what does it
mean for a match to correspond to a
computation history you'll see that's
going to be on my next slide
oh so this is a good question um
is my step two trying to use r to
determine whether m accepts w
well yes but i'm doing that by testing
whether whether this these dominoes have
a match
because r
is besides pcp i can only use r to test
whether things have a match
because someone asked
should step two be to use r to determine
whether m accepts w
well in effect that's what it's doing
but it's doing indirectly through
um testing whether this
um pcp whether these dominoes have a
match because those dominoes are going
to force you to simulate mlw
okay i think i'm repeating myself here
so let's uh avoid getting into a loop on
the lecture and um
uh see how we actually build piece of mw
so now you understand what you have to
under have the plan in your mind
uh
um
we are given m w
we're trying to make a set of dominoes
where a match is going to be
a computation history for m w so the
string you're going to get in that match
the top string and the bottom string
which are going to be you have to have
to have to match
um there they're going to be computation
histories
but they're going to be a computation
history of m w so i want to figure out
how to make my dominoes force that
okay
so my starting domino as i told you
there's going to be a special starting
domino in my collection so which is
going to require the match to start with
that domino it's going to be this one
here
it's going to have these two strings in
it
and you can see already it's starting to
look like a
a computation history
the dominoes going to have that
feature
so
uh it's the pair of strings and i've
written it kind of to help you see
what's kind of going on it's a pound
sign on the top
and the
the starting configuration for mmw on
the bottom
and what i'm going to do for you here
is at the bottom of the slide
i'm going to take the dominoes i've
written down so far and try to be
building a match and you'll see how that
match is forcing a simulation of the
machine
okay
so let's take this as an illustration
let's assume the input to m
so i'm running m on w now i'm trying to
see does m accept w
um w is a string two two three
so the
start configuration for m on w
is
q zero that's the starting state for m
and then w following is 2 2 3 that's
what it's going to appear on the on the
tape of the turing machine to start off
so this is the start configuration
for on w
and
assuming that i had this particular
string is input string to w
and so uh given the match
the dominoes that i've given you so far
just one
um this is how the match is going to
start
uh now there's going to be more dominoes
coming
so for every possible tape symbol and
state
don't get confused by the language here
this is the important thing if if in the
turing machine
um and i'll just read this in english to
you if the turing machine when it's in
state q
and the head is reading an a
it moves to state r
writes a b at that point
and its head moves to the right
i'm focusing on right rightward moving
uh
turing machine steps right now
but for every possible
uh
state and and tape symbol
and looking at where what happens
i'm going to have a
domino that's going to capture this
information
and it's going to be this domino here
q a
on top
br on the bottom so just the string qa
on the top
br on the bottom
so let's see why with that sort of
arcane looking
why is that a good thing to why is that
a useful domino to put in here
well if you take a look
um
let's assume from my turing machine
when it's in state q0 which is the
starting state and the head is reading a
two which it will happen to be reading
because the
uh this the string w starts with a two
if it goes into state q4 no q7 and
writes a four and then moves right
i'm going to have in this in this domino
i'm going to have
q02 on top
and 4
q7 on the bottom
because 4 is what i wrote right here
that's you know that's the b
and this and the new state that i'm
going into is q7
so that's going to be this
the domino that i'm going to get
and here it is here's that domino
appearing in the match
so um
it's going to take
match up with q q 0 2
um
which you know
you know don't forget the the the top
string has to equal the bottom string so
and this is going to be the only choice
that i have for extending the match so
q02 um is going to be on the top when i
put that there but that's going to force
um 427 to appear at the bottom because
that's what's going to be the bottom
string corresponding to the q02 on the
top
okay
so
if you're looking down here this is the
the beginning of the second
configuration of the machine that's what
i want to be happening
i want to be
for
that match should look like a
computation history
so now um so this is going to be all
possible right moves are going to be
handled in this way it's going to be a
similar process for the left moves but
let me not you know i'll leave that to
your imagination
now
how do i continue on from there what
does the rest of this configuration look
like
well that should just be a copying over
of the remaining symbols that were on
the tape because they don't change
things only change around the head
the rest of those symbols which is the
two and the three those should just get
copied over here so i'm gonna have two
additional
i'm gonna have additional uh symbols in
my dominoes in my uh
in my collection so for every
um
tape symbol i'm gonna have a a
be a
domino so and for every type symbol a
i'm going to have a a be a domino in my
collection
and so that says
uh
i can have
uh so that there's going to be a 2 2
domino so i can match up this 2 over
here but that forces me to put a 2 down
over there
there's also going to be a 3 3 domino
which is going to match up with that 3
but it's going to force me to push it
put a 3 down over there that's the only
way i can extend this
um
match that i've built so far
i have no choice
those are the only
dominoes that i'm going to be given
and by and so doing i'm forcing you to
basically simulate the machine
now what i want to have happen next is a
pound sign to appear here and that will
conclude my second configuration
so there's going to be a pound sign
pound sign domino as well because
there's a pound sign here
it's going to get matched with a pound
sign up top forces a pound sign to come
down um on the bottom
and if you look at where we are right
now we're exactly like where we were at
the beginning when we had just this
first domino appearing but now we're one
configuration later
so if you understood that
and i admit it it's it's
you know this is a there's just one idea
here um
[Music]
and
once you get the idea
it's all trivial it's all very simple
but there's just you have to get that
idea i'm trying to figure out how to get
that idea into your head once you get
the idea you can write all this stuff
yourself
um
so uh
so following the this uh the this
description of how uh the you know the
the transition function of the machine
works and copying over uh the symbols
from the tape to the next configuration
i'm going to be able to get
configuration after configuration going
until i get to a point when there's an
accept
and now from the machine's perspective
we're done
the machine has accepted its input this
is our computation history but is it a
match
well
you know up until this this bottom thing
um is the computation history but it's
not a match because the top doesn't
equal the bottom there's still extra
stuff at the bottom which the top is not
uh
you know
it doesn't have
so what i'm going to need to do now is
is add some additional kind of
pseudo steps of the machine
where i'm going to allow
the top to catch up to the bottom
and the way i'm going to be thinking
about that and this is not real for a
turning machine as much as the turn
machine's real anyway but you're going
to imagine i'm going to add
a new kind of uh move to the machine
which is going to allow the head to eat
the symbols off the tape
like pac-man
okay and the way i'm gonna get that
effect um
on the top if i have any tape symbol
next to a cue except on either side
on the top
what i'm going to get you to write on
the bottom is just to accept with that
taste with that tape symbol gone
and by repeating that
you know move after move the the the
actual tape is going to be shrinking the
symbols on the tape are going to be
going down one by one move by move until
there's nothing left except just the um
you accept all by itself
okay so i have this sort of pac-man idea
of eating the symbols on the tape um
and then
finally i get to a point when there's
just the cue except
alone on the tape there's no symbols
left to consume
and then i'm going to add one last
domino here which is q accept pound
pound matching with just pound which
just conveniently
finishes off the um
uh the
uh the match
and so the match is completed
there's actually a little detail here i
i hesitate even to bring it up because i
i think it's a kind of thing where if
you understand everything up to this
point you could fill it in yourself but
just for completeness sake
uh you have to deal with the situation
when the the
uh the head
um of the turing machine
might move into the blank portion of the
tape
which is not taken into account here and
the way we get that effect is by having
another domino here which allows me to
add blank symbols at the bottom as
needed
that's just a detail
you know i'm more worried that you
understand the underlying concept um
so here's going to be um
uh
a check-in um
trying to remember
um
okay but you know
so okay so
what else can we conclude from this
information
we know so at this point we know that
pcp is undecidable that's what we just
finished proving
what else do we know
if anything
or do we even know that
uh see my picture is a little bit
covering the check in but it's still
readable
so i mean this is not an easy concept to
get the to get the idea but once you get
it
you know it's um
you know it's you'll see it's not that
bad
okay
another 15 seconds
so this portion doesn't this question is
not really relying so much on the
computation history method it's just
relying on the fact about
pcp being undecidable
um
[Music]
okay everybody
almost done
five seconds
all right
um
so i can see that there is uh
some level of confusion um
uh so the reason why b is correct
is that
we know pcp is undecidable
but
we also know that it's recognizable
because you could try all possible
uh ways of combining dominoes
and
one after the
next um and you accept if you ever find
a match
so they might go forever but if there is
a match
uh possible you'll find it eventually so
pcp is a recognizable language
undecidable and so therefore we know
it's complement it has to be
unrecognizable because you know that's
something we've shown before if a
language and its complement are both
recognizable then it's decidable but we
know pcp is not decidable so they both
both sides can't be recognizable
um okay so let's
let me prove to you one last theorem
that's going to be useful for your
homework
uh involving the computation history
method so you'll have one last chance
to get the
way we're going to use this though this
one is going to be a little bit more
similar in spirit
to the lba version
uh than to the pcp version which has
this extra kind of complication about
coding the computations of the machine
into dominoes here um you know we're
going to operate with another automaton
which where it's going to be more
straightforward but anyway okay getting
ahead of myself
so if you remember for the for
context-free grammars we had the
problem the emptiness problem
we showed that was decidable
so testing whether a context-free
grammar's language is empty
is decidable
however testing whether a context-free
grammar's language is everything whether
it's equal to sigma star
that turns out to be um
uh that turns out to be undecidable
okay so emptiness testing for
context-free grammars decidable
sigma-star testing
undecidable
um
okay so
we'll show that atm is reducible to all
pda via the computation history method
um
and uh
so uh assume we have same patterns
assuming we have a decider for all pda
and make a decider for ulti
decider for atm
here's the atm decider
and now
similar to what we did for the
uh
lba case but with a with a twist
we're going to make a push down
automaton
that's going to check its input to see
whether it's an accepting computation
history of m w just like the lba did if
you think back to how that worked
remember remember you know we um the lba
tested its input to see whether it's uh
an accepting computation history accept
it if it did and then we test the lba's
language for emptiness to see if there
are any computation histories so we're
doing the same kind of thing
except now
uh the pda is going to test its input to
see whether it's a an accepting
computation history and if it is it's
going to reject
it's going to do
the reverse of what the lba
did
and that's going to turn out to be
necessary but for the for the moment
let's just go with it and maybe we'll
see in the proof why the proof needs it
to be this way
so um this p pushdown automaton is going
to accept its input if it's not
an accepting computation history for m
on w otherwise it will accept so you can
think of this pda
as
accepting all the junk
it just
doesn't accept
um the good stuff the accepting
computation history
okay it's it's just it it's uh accepting
all the things which fail
to be an accepting computation history
okay and then once we have that we we
test whether
ours language is everything but whether
bmw's languages everything using r
because it if if that pda's language is
everything
then we know um
uh
there could not be an accepting
computation history because that's the
one thing that gets um
not accepted that's the one thing that
gets rejected
so if it's accepting everything there is
not going to be an accepting computation
history
so if there is no
uh if this is equal to sigma star
then there couldn't be an accepting
computation history and so we're going
to accept
okay so how is this going to work so
what's different now
about uh this case
uh from the lba case is remember the lba
uh got you know in
the the computation history on its input
and it used its ability to write on the
tape to check that each
configuration follows the next one
we don't have the ability to write on
the tape and push on automaton and by
the way i hope you're all comfortable
with my using pdas instead of grammars
because we can interchange one to the
other um i should have mentioned that
when when i did it but
um
so the the pda is going to be using its
stack to compare each configuration with
the next one
okay
so the way that's going to happen is
it's going to non-deterministically
take one of these so the very first
thing it does
is as before it checks to make sure that
the beginning
of the input is the start configuration
but then once that's that's the easy
part but once we get going with that we
can we push each configuration well we
first of all we now deterministically
choose which configuration might be the
bet the one that fails
um
where
where one fails to go to the next one
because those are the ones we're trying
to accept when there's a failure
so we now deterministically look for the
place that there's a failure we push
that onto the stack
um and then we pop it off the stack and
compare it with the next configuration
so that's how we're using the stack
instead of being able to mark on the
input
now there's a so i'm kind of going to
illustrate that here
so
you know we're going as we're going to
read this thing here and we're going to
put it onto the stack so this thing
moves over to here
and
this input here got put onto the stack
you know q 0 w 1 w 2 it's q 0 w 1 w 2
you see that that first configuration is
now sitting on the stack now as we're
going to pop it off we're going to match
it with the second configuration
now if you're following me
you'll realize that there's a there's a
difficulty here because it's coming out
in reverse
you know it comes out in the reverse
order that we put it in and that's not
what we need to do so what we're going
to do here and here's a little sort of a
twist we're going to change the way
we're writing down computation histories
by making them by writing them uh
reversing the even numbered ones so this
one here is going to be written down in
reverse
and that's perfectly okay we can write
down configuration computation histories
in any way we want
to um to meet our needs so we're going
to reverse we're going to reverse the
alternate ones
and now when we push one it's going to
come off in the right order to compare
with the next one
and so that's how the the procedure
works
okay
we're running a little short on time um
you need to be let's see so let let me
just go to um
uh
quick recap the computation history
method is useful for showing the
undecidability of problems when you're
testing for the existence of an object
each of those four cases that we showed
today involving testing whether
something exists
so is there an integer solution to the
polynomial
is there some string in the language is
there a string that's not in the
language
um or is there a match
so that's a typical case
when um
this computation history method comes up
and so as a quick review
uh these are the things we showed today
okay so why don't we uh uh we're we're
just out of time um and so i'm i'm gonna
let you go um
but i will stick around uh for another
five minutes or ten minutes uh happy to
answer any questions if you if you have
them um but that's that's officially the
end of the lecture
um okay
so let's let me try to get to there's a
lot of questions in the chat don't
forget you know write to the tas too
so
if m does not accept w
what will happen to the computation
history so if m does not accept w
um
uh then there is no computation there is
no accepting computation history that's
the only kind of computation histories
we're considering
so if m does not accept w there is no
accepting computation history there's no
computation history
um so i don't know what it means what
will happen to it it just doesn't
doesn't exist
um
so uh
i hope that's
helpful um
don't we need to be able to add states
to the end of the tape
i don't know what that means
it's taped to the end of the tape
i i don't know you'll have to repeat
that one sorry or explain that better
um
ah
so this is a good this is a very good
question here where does the previous
proof fail
when trying to reduce atm to
ecfg
it's got to fail
because ecfg is
decidable um
so that that's a very good question
maybe we can just go back to that
last slide here
because i was running a little short on
time i didn't really focus on why we
have to accept
um
the non-computation history strings we
why are we accepting all the junk
strings
and
only rejecting
um
the strings which are the uh the
computation histories so you know we're
looking for strings that fail
you know if the string could fail
because it starts wrong
string it doesn't have the start
configurat configuration or it doesn't
maybe doesn't end with the accepting
configuration or maybe one configuration
doesn't lead properly to the next one
any of those cases are a failure
and there are going to be reason to
accept
the reason why we can do do it do that
um is because the we're taking advantage
of the push downs non-determinism
we don't know where the
um the failure
might occur
so we're going to non-deterministically
guess where that failure occurs
if we were going to flip this around and
say
let's accept only the good ones and
reject everything else we would have to
test that each configuration led to the
next one
so we have to check them all
so
if something fails it only has to fail
in one place
and then you know we can accept if it um
if it's a good computation history
we have to
it has to be good everywhere
and so the push down automaton really if
you're going to get down to the
nitty-gritty the push on automaton can
check that this configuration leads to
that configuration
using pushing on the stack and then
popping it
but now by the time you get to here you
want to check that this second
configuration leads to the third one
you would need to push the second
configuration onto the stack but at this
point you're already
at after the second configuration so we
cannot back up and push the second one
on the stack
so the the push on tom dot is not able
to check um in the positive sense that
you have a computation history it's only
able to and accept them it's only to
check in the negative sense that you
don't have a con
a computation history
and uh accept all the ones that fail
and that's just because it only has to
fail in one place
i hope that helps um
so that's why we couldn't flip this
around and make this proof work for the
emptiness problem and only have to work
for the the everything problem
the old problem
all right um
okay so bye bye everybody and i will see
you on tuesday